mit ihrem einsatz belegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
achtsamkeit in aller munde
achtsamkeit
sogar im kriminalroman wird achtsam
gemordet
viele kulturschaffende setzen auf
achtsamkeit
[Musik]
ein vielversprechendes konzept wo liegen
die chancen wo gefahr
kulturplatz sucht ruhe in der welt der
buddhas und schaut achtsam auf ein
phänomen
[Musik]
wir kommen nach den kulturplatz ja wir
wollen ihnen heute kurz vor weihnachten
eine portion ruhe schenken einatmen
ausatmen achtsamkeit ist unser thema
achtsamkeit längst mehr als ein modewort
sondern ein riesiger trend und auch ein
richtig großer macht wir alle sehnen uns
nach innerer klarheit nach gelassenheit
erst recht in diesen zeiten der pandemie
wie das funktionieren kann das wollen
herausfinden und zwar hier im museum der
kulturen in basel
aber zuerst da wollen wir ihnen zeigen
wie weit ist das thema achtsamkeit schon
gebracht hat denn auf der spiegel
bestsellerliste steht seit unglaublichen
zweieinhalb jahren an krimi mit dem
titel achtsam morgen achtsamkeit und
morden wir wollen wissen wie das
zusammengeht
[Musik]
ganz im hier und jetzt sein ohne den
moment zu bewerten
sich ruhig und gelassen fokussieren
doch was wenn achtsamkeit und innere
ruhe gestört hätten und nur ein wort das
problem vermeintlich zu lösen vermag
klingt paradox doch exakt mit diesem
gedanken experiment sorgt carsten es für
moritz mäßiges aufsehen achtsamkeit im
ort verbindet das passe ihre brutale
fallhöhe fernsehfilm ins tor
fabian und trecker comedian und arzt hat
für uns die neue gattung krimi inklusive
ernst gemeinter lebenshilfe seziert
während autor carsten des achtsam darauf
bedacht war den medien rummel zu
entgehen
wir nehmen es mit humor
kommt in salzburg es ist sehr lustig und
es ist komplexer so einen gedanken bis
zum ende durchziehen der reihe nach am
anfang der achtsame roman reihe steht
mafiosi anwalt gern diemel dessen
work-life-balance arg in schieflage
geraten ist seine frau zwingt ihn zu
einem achtsamkeitstraining und die ehe
zu retten doch dieses trägt umgarnte
früchte nach 48 stunden beginnt björn
diemel zu morden fokussiert nach allen
regeln der achtsamkeit
zitat
erstens bemerkten sie die absicht dessen
was sie gleich tun werden
zweitens atmen sie einmal ein und wieder
aus
als ich wieder im zelt stand bemerkte
ich also ganz bewusst meine absicht dass
ich trage an zunächst im kopf absägen
wollte ich atme tief ein
er will das im grunde aber fühlt sich
jetzt trotzdem der achtsamkeit pflichtet
und resultat von der achtsamkeit ist
dann kriminalität und drogen jahr das
funktioniert als comedian ist fabian
unteregger überzeugt als arzt jedoch hat
er einen einwand in bezug auf das
rasante morden denn achtsamkeit zu
lernen erfordere zeit im
auto aber obwohl du erschwerte die dank
abstreifen oder abschweifen das passiert
also schnell 20 sekunden wir sind gar
nicht in der lage zum lang der focus
selber wo lang focus hat erklärt hat zu
meditieren
der fokus auf den moment zu
unterscheiden und anstrengender prozess
autor kasten dies hat auch dies ad
absurdum geführt
bekannt wurde rechtsanwalt des alls
straßen reporter wolf aus holz in der
rtl comedy sendung freitag nacht news
achtsam morden war sein erster roman
gleich ein bestseller ich würde sogar
unterricht beim empfehlen ich find
hervorragend dass eine dortmund hat ein
tabu thema wie eigentlich morde lustig
verpackt er will ganz greifbar ist er
sich gedanken mit cli mieter vergrössern
sache und es enttabuisiert und
enttabuisierung
und was bleibt
carsten des hatte den mut die viel
gepriesene achtsamkeit lehre mit mord zu
fahren
fabian unteregger hätte sich diesen
einfall vielleicht für sein comedy
programm gewünscht und wir haben
augenzwinkernd einen überraschenden
blick aufs thema erhascht und sind davon
überzeugt wer schwarzem humor mag hat
nach der lektüre ein lächeln im gesicht
[Musik]
wir sind zurück hier im museum der
kulturen in basel und wollen nun der
achtsamkeit auf die spur kommen und zwar
in der ausstellung erleichtert
ihren ursprung hat die achtsamkeit lehre
im buddhismus im westen spielte sie
früher als oft gedacht eine rolle und
zwar dank philosophen wie immanuel kant
der über buddhismus vorlesungen hielt
oder arthur schopenhauer der sich mit
meditation beschäftigte
einen regelrechten boom gab es dann in
den 1960 er jahren dank der hippie
bewegung wurde der buddhismus immer
populärer und auch die beatles die im
nordindischen ashram des maharishi
erleuchtung suchten trugen dazu bei dass
der westen sich vom buddhismus
verzaubern ließ
ende der 70er jahre entwickelte der
molekularbiologe jon kabat zinn aus
unterschiedlichen meditationstechniken
schließlich sein meint von espace stress
reduction programm kurz m bsr und löste
damit die meditation aus ihrem
religiösen kontext das ziel
stressreduktion
[Musik]
von den gestalten
regel langsamer sie sind achtsamkeit
trainerin und psychotherapeuten und
kantorin eine wunderbare ruhe auch für
die meditationen man sieht ihn gekümmert
und dir gut ausgesehen das ist jetzt
wirklich kaputt ist ist ständig was
macht das mit jenen von anderen dass ihr
zustand wo für mich ist eigentlich kunst
werk wo alle zimmer gemacht sich von
menschlicher hand und ganz tief in der
st in die präsenz in ich sehe worden das
kunstwerk gemacht hat und das löst bei
mir eigentlich ganz
stabilität
[Musik]
in aller munde ist alle heilmittel
ja
das ist
wirklich wirklich
besondere aufmerksamkeit meint was
meinst du wirklich dass vitali verstand
wenn er klar oder lichter klare den muss
man sich das vorstellen wie ein vogel
mit zwei flügeln und der ein geflügelter
aufmerksamkeit wirklich brisant kino
analogen und rui und der andere flügel
ich oder ein vogel ist liebe und
vogel fliegt nicht wenn ein flügel und
wenn sie erklären was denn eigentlich wo
es passiert war meditiert
längerfristig meditiert über zwei monate
oder nur länger denn nachher kann man
auch ich selber merke dass man immer so
reaktiv
der mann im labor machen also wenn ich
zum beispiel im ruf weg wäre eigentlich
vom mini stimme gerade dass ich in
reaktion kann ich mich zurückziehen
das heißt und bewusst die bewusste geht
dazwischen will ich das wirklich will
vier mal wenn man in der reaktion gott
denn du musst eigentlich nach rapids
bereue und
wandern china ganz genau was würden sie
manchmal wo jetzt auf fang meditiere
sagte russischen gut die größenordnung
zum meditieren wenn du die längere
versank sondern wie viel
will ich nicht einmal im minute vor
liebe sondern ajax york bewusst mache
wenn ich war da der bus haltestation
heute zum beispiel dem ik von in der
schlager das kennen wir jetzt gut dass
ich denn statt dass er um einander
locker mal mit billig also meine
aufmerksamkeit
wohlwollend gegenüber zu wenden und in
dem moment einfach noch mal gespürt was
jetzt durchgeht mancher tennessee würde
ganz klar
profitiert es gibt situationen im leben
zum beispiel wort meditation die du
unbedingt wird gemacht werde das ist in
dem moment wo man gerade ist innere
krise steckt dort domäne der rote worden
die innere worden habe ich nutz
erweitere sondern den darüber
nachgedacht am kai timm alltag eben dann
wo man macht er zwar mann psychisch
krank ist oder wann sie mit gut geht
dann hat man das gefühl es ist
unveränderbar was würden sie sagen ist
der mann schwer an der bar ist ziel auf
andere wenn man zum beispiel sich oft
meditativ also grund herzlicher sich
selber kaufe angriff das ist eigentlich
nie motivation überhaupt mit grundsatz
es ist mir bis wirklich bleibt natürlich
nicht immer gleich mehr freunde wenn ich
jeden moment und klar haben wir
möglichkeiten bis andere staatsbürger
und das ist letztendlich vom munitions
staudämme besonders gesehen
jau kunststoffen die sätze durch
meditation und achtsamkeit training und
wie sie das genau macht da dazu haben
wir drei von ihnen gefragt
rapperin steff la cheffe locker magst du
rat
schauspielerin laura biehler
sie alle sind mit die menschen
herausforderungen in ihren
künstlerischen berufen konvertiert
konkurrenzkampf neid kritik leistungs
und erfolgsteam ich ein probates mittel
auch für steff la cheffe achtsamkeit
sich mit dem körper verbinden und tief
atmen damit erreiche sie eine art
gleichmut
schlacht die kritik
genauso wie gute kritiken kompliment
ich
lernen sich nicht von der reinen stimmen
anderer abhängig zu machen das kennt
auch magst du rage
1980 wurde der gebürtige malteser lead
sänger der schweizer band krokus
welttournee 15 millionen verkaufte
tonträger
aber auch streitereien und trennungen
legendär
jetzt mit 70 historische es noch einmal
wissen mit neuer band und solo album
sex drugs rock'n'roll
und meditation kein widerspruch musiker
sind sensibler mensch wertet der das
nicht spüren die die finesse es ist
nicht nur durch darf klar stuft dakar
[Musik]
auf tour sei schon die kleinste
meditation ein segen
sie immer neu kleine am anfang ist das
umso schöner
und nachher nachdem der us ich denke
dass bentley eine zerreißprobe
du hast schnauze voll und es wird
schlimmer und einwender nacht kommt und
mehr fahren und alle gehen langsam
geschlafen und das habe gott zieht wenn
du für dich wünschen bis unter die
eigenen gedanken und
[Musik]
meditation
die 24 jährige schauspielerin jana
beller brillierte eben in ihrer ersten
filme hauptrolle im münchner tatort
riems mimte die laien geigerin
glaubwürdig eine ausnahmemusikerin mit
instrument vor der kamera stehen eine
neue erfahrung dafür wurde sie extra von
einer violinistin gecoacht auch mit
meditation
[Musik]
und ich finde sowieso das ist ganz angst
ich
spiele kann ich ja nervosität und wenn
man zehn flügen zittere kann ich das
irgendwie mit einer rolle und irgendwie
ein verwandter für sie emotionen und für
spannung sorgt in den gegner in die
hände
spiele den körper wieder tickets zu
haben also viele musikerinnen und so
klasse schienen die
stände und mega druck oder kenne das
problem aber also das phänomen von der
buche wie tae bok
wenige lehrerinnen hätten wir sowieso
für sie bilder versucht mit skates dass
man sie innerlich eine
entspannung bringt
reformen die gespielt
seit dieser spielzeit ist bieler mon
sommer des jungen schauspielhaus hamburg
für sie gehört achtsamkeit selbstredend
zum beruf
sex vor der kamera doch die bringen es
wird mir ja immer total nachdem man sie
und ab in partner c und das was einen
total müssen momentum so holte man fragt
sich bewährt also wenn wir heute gefragt
danke sogar das spielrecht durch das
klappt wirklich kein schein
selbstzweifel für viele künstlerinnen
und künstler ein unliebsamer begleiter
viele quälen sich mit fragen wie packe
ich die nächste rolle
hoppe ich den erfolg des letzten albums
woher bekomme ich die inspiration
ideen nachzujagen versucht steff la
cheffe mittlerweile achtsam zu vermeiden
die weg beamer
zu je länger die rund die hälfte dass
sie bitter dass sie wie
normale figur muss neue immer hart zu
mini daher findet also weiter mit dem
kopf und bekannte sind im körper sondern
meldete sich hierbei und insb und das
wiederum vertrauen dass weniger präsent
und ruhig wie
die der nach
sein und zur ruhe kommen das gelingt dem
rocker magst du ratsche der in der nähe
von basel wohnt am besten in den
altehrwürdigen mauern des schlosses
ottfingen seit mehreren jahren ein
wertvoller rückzugsort für den sänger
doch am besten abschalten
und so gedankengang die ihr tier fiel
ganz tiefe gedanken wo
muss kein lied um dich habe ich keine
oder
wieso bist weil das das bringt die
wirklich
oktober flache wieder ich muss keine
villa fischer
sowie
max turaci
steff la cheffe
jana beller
drei kulturschaffende die den
anforderungen ihres berufes mit 86
gelassener begegnen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
jetzt haben die kunststoffen texeira
achtsamkeit ihres beruflich integriert
jetzt geht sie auch hier immer mehr wo
achtsamkeitstraining
anbietet über die mieter das bienenhaus
hütet alarmglocken so krass ist
optimiert für dir wo dann mit schafen
oder finden sie das begrüßenswert ich
froh gewesen wenn mir rat fragte
natürlich auch was ich den job sie
verdammen und ich glaube viel mal ist es
so dass wir wirklich gesundheit nicht
die förderung für den erhöht und das ich
in guter absicht und da kann man
wirklich sagen jetzt haben mit
achtsamkeit auch im bezug oder als
antithese zu der plan krieg betrachtet
weisen vertrauen der mannschaft zum
beispiel dass der plan krieg das
wichtigste moment ist also nicht nur
achtsam sie oft zeige die befinden
sondern vielleicht auch eine sich ab zu
lang mit was allem weil viele bürger
theater was immer das nur will würde
dies unterstütze folgen kannst also dass
ich ganz wichtig das heißt ja eigentlich
nämlich sehr wohl und ich tue was jetzt
im moment wirklich für tag für zustand
was ich brauche wenn der innere versenkt
oder in der youngster und danach alle
heißen muss mit ihren sitzen blieben in
meiner situation sondern dass du wo
ihnen der situation stabilisiert und ich
finde das eigentlich nicht ablenken
sondern dass ich sage wenn es
langfristig gut 30
wir sind heute hier im museum der
kulturen in der buddhistischen
ausstellung erleuchtet und da passt es
gut über die schweizerin steht ein
schicksal zu sprechen soeben hat die
mantras sängerin eine neue cd
herausgebracht wir wollten von der
buddhistin wissen was sie vom westlichen
super trend der achtsamkeit hält
[Musik]
meditation machen für den weltlichen
geprüft einfach dass es einem selber
schmeckt besser es ist
aber es ist schade wenn
eigentlich
möglichkeit hat zum eigenen alle wachen
wie die butter selbst wenn man das dann
einfach nicht wahrnimmt
[Musik]
das schon genau diagnose von buddha dass
er sämtliche wesen haben der natur in
sich das ist es seine unterstützer
energien die mutter natur
und wenn wir meditieren kurz aber bloß
darum dass mer all das was eure mutter
natur verdeckt eigentlich schön schicht
für schicht
abhebt zum den hans g
[Musik]
spd
und
ich bin mit zwei
halbjährigen
mein in 238 mit schweizer haben wir die
ganze familie soll es zeigen nachdem sie
ihren 50 kilos tiefe geflüchtet sind
wächst der chinesische
besatzung und miss mami hat mir erwartet
im buch und hat so sucht wieder
geschafft ich bin erst nach der flucht
einen apple geboren und was seine praxis
hat sie die tragische nachricht dass
ihre man also mit lieblicher vater nie
mehr trubel es geschafft
extra-service
ist es passiert der mannschaft aber dann
ist ganz klar das im ersten moment sehr
viel wut und hass fordernden ist das ist
so manche
und auch ich bin durch zugang nicht
kenne ich überhaupt nicht einverstanden
sind wieder verschwunden
die seele zurück und die große chance
natürlich mit eine neue fertig das noch
schlimmer gewählt das macht mir
natürlich sorgen aber wir sind für
unsere älteren er zucker wurde dass wir
sie feinde im gebet mit ihm schließlich
werde kein land der sängerin wenn ich
nicht
eigentlich immer das gute von der manche
glauben
und dann gehört dass wir die musik in
tränen aufgelöst wird er hat das sehr
schlecht glaubt dann bin ich mal ist
internet und hat tatsächlich krebs hat
meine musik und sie sind sich bewusst
dass sie jetzt musik forderte pöttering
gefunden
[Musik]
achtsamkeit ist der künstlerische
tätigkeit finde ich aber sehr wichtig
vor allem wenn man selber mit der
stimmen schaffen
maha unmöglich der tontöpfe weil man
nicht achtsam isst dann klingt das
einfach nicht
es ist natürlich schon also dass dir
dass der gesamt vor dem man groß das
kernteam von dem anlass dass dort in
erster linie 1 ab sofort beruhigen
[Musik]
manche alle viel viel singen das
bedeutet nicht virtuos
kondoms schönsten songs
in die melodie zu finden es geht darum
dass man sich in der musik wieder gehört
und ich glaube das haben wir noch nie
verlor
tote
[Musik]
ja das sind ja schön wo denn seit die
eigene tisch team wieder finden nur
dritter mit gesamt das wird als eine
klinge oder was sagen sie dazu
da wir nicht eigentlich und was hätte
und ich glaube
ihnen einfach einen euro und bei euch
sein die
da momentan finde wo es glücklich ist
und glücklich obwohl alles zweimal lesen
wenn man mal sehr schwierig ist und das
ist ein teil auf und macht haben sie das
man wohl ist mit seh das ganz vieles so
schwierig ist dass matthäus im kleinen
eigentlich ruhe finden und so wiederum
in der walter bis zur aufgabe jetzt gibt
es ja ratgeberliteratur wo boom zum
thema achtsamkeit wo was würden sie für
ihren tipp gruselig aussetzt wenn ich
nicht lernen sievernich wird lernen
meditiere ja wenn sie möchte lehre
meditiere demnach an ist aber einfachste
wäre es aber ladet auf
telefon und mal einfach zu lust wieder
leute gesehen und dennis bührer und da
viele schreckliche von jon kabat zinn
oder was der noch haare möglich ist dass
mir wirklich kunst sucht wo es menschen
gibt oder training war man keinen
anleiten und überlegt einmal auf flüssig
fahren können aufmerksam machen und dort
einmal holt gabe herzlich dafür dass
gebracht
[Musik]
yahoo
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wer den buddhistischen zustand der
erleuchtung zu erreichen das dürfte den
wenigsten von uns gelingen aber
erleuchtung kann ja auch bedeuten dass
uns immer wieder mal ein lichtlein auf
geht in diesem sinne wünschen wir von
kulturplatz ganz viel licht gleich jetzt
fauzy auf sf1 die sternstunde
philosophie und schaut in die zukunft
und wir wir sehen uns wieder in naher
zukunft nämlich im neuen jahr und
wünschen ihnen von herzen frohe festtage
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos